(suspenseful music)
- I am a singer.
- I'm a singer.
(suspenseful music)
(rhythmic ticking)
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- I wanna see a sense of confidence.
I want them to look
like they know what they're doing,
no matter what style it is.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- I was looking for
things like neck strain.
If you're reaching a higher note
you're gonna want to come up here
but that is the complete
opposite of what you want to do
when you want to open up this area
to allow your voice to come through.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- I just do want to say I do get loud.
♪ Happy birthday dear your name ♪
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- I could definitely hear that.
- I'll have this mic.
I don't wanna pull a Gabbie Hanna.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday dear Jubilee ♪
- That mic adjustment,
I just felt that he didn't even really
adjust the mic well at all.
- He adjusted it like this,
but didn't adjust the actual stand.
I got a little suspicious
that he wasn't familiar with
working with mic stands.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- I was looking for at least posture.
Hands in the pockets is like,
(bell dings)
such a no-
- [Voiceover] Nope.
- In singing.
♪ Happy Birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- He seemed super silly
but it just didn't give me singer vibes.
It gave me like comedian vibes.
♪ Happy birthday, Mr President ♪
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- [Producer] Nailed it,
thank you, my friend.
- When Josh got up and started singing
he took it very lightly
and he started kinda doing
things in a silly way
and it kind of made me feel
like maybe he wasn't a singer.
- He had his hands in his pockets.
And one thing that we were told in choir
was never have your hands in your pockets,
always on your side.
(strikes ticking)
- It was body language.
I was like, okay, you're doing the most.
You were like,
I'm like it's just happy birthday.
Calm down.
(buzzer rings)
(Vidal squeals)
(Vidal cries)
(Tiana laughs)
(Brennan chuckles)
- [Ashley] Sorry.
- [Christian] Sorry.
- That's okay.
(contestants giggling)
My strategy was, pretend to
be shy, pretend you can't sing
and then they're going to
judge you that you can't sing.
When in reality I can sing and
that's exactly what happened.
- What kind of music do we sing?
- I'm like a contemporary
R&B type of person,
sprinkled with a little bit of pop.
- Cool.
- Yeah,
and can I ask, do you do live performances
or do you record in a
studio or at home or both?
- Both, I have live, I do live music
and then I have like my
own recorded music as well,
that I've put out over the past few years.
If you wanna check it out on Spotify
and all those other spots, check it out.
- I started training in 2015.
I grew up not musical almost at all.
- And what got you into music?
- Yeah, feeling a little
lost when I was younger,
not knowing what I wanted
to do when I grew up.
Going to concerts and
like witnessing the effect
of like a lively lead singer,
that was when like everything felt
like it was connecting.
- [Producer] Is there a specific concert
that you remember being like?
(picture pops)
- Walk the Moon?
- [Producer] Yeah?
- Walk the Moon, 2012 Nic Petricca.
- [Producer] Wow.
- I am into hardcore
thrash metal, new metal.
I guess the look kind of gives it away.
- [Tiana] Yeah, you look like-
- We could tell from the stance.
(all laughing)
Ashley, do you wanna answer your question?
- Yeah, I'm an opera singer.
- Okay.
- Oh, okay.
- So yeah, I've started
training since I was 14
but I've been singing my whole life.
I've been doing it professionally
for about a decade now.
- Awesome.
- Been a crazy career.
I love opera because
of how dramatic it is.
Everything is heightened.
It is the most dramatic
thing and I love it.
- What do you sing?
I'm curious about what you do.
- Okay, I'm classically trained.
I got started in choral
music when I was four.
So I've been singing live most
of my career professionally
but actually in the last couple years,
I've transitioned into
more sync licensing.
Like anytime you're watching a TV show
or a movie or whatever,
and you hear music in the
background, that's what that is.
(bell dings)
(upbeat jazzy music)
- What was your vocal range?
- Like note to note?
- Like are you an alto, are you a bass?
- I think I'm a tenor.
I think I can go
from a G flat two
(low piano note dings)
to a G flat five,
(high piano note dings)
I think.
- Okay.
- Got some range.
- [Shannon] That might work.
- I like that.
- [Producer] Can you hit
a whistle note for me?
(Brennan laughs)
- Okay, hold on.
(Brennan screeches)
(Brennan laughs)
- I don't have a lot
of classical training.
I do musical improv.
So when I first got to LA,
I got really into improv
and then took a musical improv class
and I was like, this is so much fun.
- When did you start doing that?
Like training for that, I guess.
- So, I took my first
musical improv class in 2015
and then I took like a bunch more.
One thing I love about it,
is you don't have to
be the greatest singer.
You, as long as you're like saying yes
and like with your team-
- Mm-hmm.
- You know, you can like-
- Yeah.
- I feel like it's worth noting.
Why did anybody vote Vidal out?
For me personally, it was strictly
because his hands were in his pockets.
- I was gonna say the same thing.
His hands were in his pockets
and his posture was just standing.
And you can sing that song very easily
standing still straight.
But the one rule when
you perform in general,
is you never have your
hands in your pocket.
And that was the only dead giveaway.
- There's like no movement
for me.
(alarm bell rings)
(upbeat music)
(strikes ticking)
- I do improv and I do music
and I don't do both,
because that is really difficult. (laughs)
- Round two, I voted for Shannon,
because I was like, okay,
I don't know who to vote for right now.
I was pretty certain we
got it with Vidal already.
(buzzer rings)
- [Singers] Aww, sorry.
- I was gonna give everyone
free tickets to my improv show.
(singers laughing)
I was surprised I didn't
get voted out first.
I just felt everybody was so confident
and the fact that I made
it through two rounds,
I'm proud of it.
- [Producer] If you think
the mole is still in the box
and you wish to continue playing the game,
please raise your hand.
(suspenseful music)
Wow, we all think the
mole has been voted out.
Who do we think is the mole?
Who'd you vote for and why?
- I think it was Josh, from
the moment he started singing
he seemed to take it not as seriously
and he was kind of being silly with it.
And I know if I were
pretending to do something
that I don't normally do,
that's how I would do it.
- Like improv and music, I
don't normally hear that.
- He said specifically,
you don't have to be a
classically trained singer
or like a really skilled musician.
- You don't have to be
the greatest singer.
(record scratches)
- What do you mean by that?
- I hope you guys aren't a mole.
- [Singers] I know.
- I know, yeah, for real.
- [Producer] If the lights turn green,
that means you voted the
mole out and you win.
If the lights turn red
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
(suspenseful music)
(singers cheering)
(singers clapping)
- Good work everyone.
- I kind of felt like
it was gonna be easy.
Like singers always know.
- [Tiana] You kinda know.
- We always know.
- [Producer] On the count of three,
will the mole please reveal themselves?
One, two, three.
(energetic music)
- Oh.
(singers laughing)
- Knew it.
(rocker vocalizing)
- It was me.
(singers laughing)
- Wow, I did not vote for Josh ever.
I was confident it wasn't him.
- So I do do improv, but I
do not do musical improv.
I prepared a little bit,
but I was like, I'll just
improvise my way through this and-
- Classic Josh.
- And it didn't work out.
(everyone laughs)
- [Producer] I wanted to ask
you guys if you want to sing,
now that you can all hear each other.
- I'm down, I'm just gonna get loud.
That's all I gotta say.
- I wanna hear your
rendition of Happy Birthday.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday, happy birthday ♪
- All right, let me show
you guys how it's done.
- All right.
(singers cheering)
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
(singers whoop)
- Yes.
(singers laughing)
♪ Happy birthday dear nameless ♪
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
(singers cheering)
♪ Happy Birthday to you ♪
(singers gasping)
(singers laughing)